Celle que dans les 15 prochaines années,
les vies de milliards de gens s’amélioreraient
sans exclure personne.
Cette promesse, c'est les Objectifs de Développement Durable -
les ODD.
Cela fait maintenant trois ans ;
un cinquième du parcours.
Le compteur tourne.
Si nous décrochons maintenant,
ça va devenir de plus en plus difficile d'atteindre ces objectifs.
Ce que je veux aujourd’hui, c'est vous donner un aperçu
du point où nous en sommes,
quelques projections de là où nous allons
et quelques idées de ce que nous pourrions faire différemment.
Les ODD sont bien sûr spectaculairement compliqués.
Je n'attendrais rien de moins des Nations Unies.
(Rires)
Combien d'objectifs ?
Peut-être quelque chose qui a fait ses preuves, comme trois, sept ou 10.
Non, prenons un nombre premier plus grand que 10.
17 objectifs.
Je félicite ceux d'entre vous qui les ont déjà mémorisés.
Pour les autres, les voici.
17 objectifs allant de l'éradication de la pauvreté
aux villes inclusives,
aux pêches durables ;
tout un plan global pour le futur de notre monde.
Malheureusement, un plan sans données pour le mesurer.
Donc, comment mesurer l'avancement ?
Eh bien, je vais utiliser l'Indice du Progrès Social.
C'est une mesure de la qualité de vie des pays,
allant des besoins de survie de base -
la nourriture, l'eau, le toit, la sécurité -
aux fondations du bien-être -
l'éducation, l'information, la santé et l'environnement -
et l'opportunité -
les droits, la liberté de choix,
l'inclusion et l'accès à l'éducation supérieure.
Mais l'Indice du Progrès Social n'a rien à voir avec les ODD,
mais fondamentalement, il mesure les mêmes concepts,
et l'Indice de Progrès Social a l'avantage d'avoir des données.
Nous avons 51 indicateurs provenant de sources fiables
pour mesurer ces concepts.
Ce que nous pouvons aussi faire puisque c'est un index,
est d'ajouter tous ces indicateurs pour nous donner un résultat consolidé
de notre performance par rapport à l'ensemble des ODD.
Un avertissement cependant.
L'Indice du Progrès Social est une mesure de qualité de vie.
Nous ne regardons pas si cela peut être réalisé
dans les limites environnementales de la planète.
Il faudra d'autres outils pour ça.
Donc, où en sommes-nous des ODD ?
Eh bien, je vais mettre les ODD sur une échelle de zéro à 100.
Zéro étant le résultat le pire de chacun de ces 51 indicateurs :
progrès social absolu, zéro.
Et 100 étant le standard minimum pour réaliser ces ODD.
100 est ce que nous visons pour 2030.
Donc où avons-nous commencé ?
Heureusement, pas à zéro.
En 2015, le résultat mondial par rapport aux ODD était de 69,1.
Sur le bon chemin, mais la route est encore longue.
J'insiste sur le fait que cette estimation mondiale
basée sur des données de 180 pays,
est pondérée en fonction de la population.
Donc la Chine pèse plus que les Comores ;
l'Inde pèse plus que l'Islande.
Mais nous pourrions voir en détail où en est chaque pays.
Le pays aujourd’hui le plus près de réaliser les ODD, est le Danemark.
Et le pays qui a le plus de chemin à faire est la République Centrafricaine.
Et tous les autres sont quelque part entre les deux.
Donc le défi des ODD
est d'amener tous les points à droite, jusqu’à 100 d'ici 2030.
Peut-on y arriver ?
Avec l'Indice du Progrès Social, nous avons des données dans la durée.
Donc, nous avons une idée de la tendance dans chaque pays,
sur laquelle nous pouvons nous projeter.
Regardons ensemble.
Commençons par le pays le plus performant, le Danemark.
Et oui, je suis heureux d'annoncer que
le Danemark devrait atteindre les ODD en 2030.
Pas surprenant, peut-être, mais je tiens le vainqueur.
Regardons quelques autres pays riches du monde -
le G7.
Nous voyons que l'Allemagne et le Japon y arriveront ou presque.
Mais le Canada et la France, la GB et l'Italie échoueront de peu.
Et les États-Unis ?
Un peu en arrière.
Bon, ce ne sont pas des nouvelles très rassurantes.
Mais ce sont les pays les plus riches du monde,
pas les plus peuplés.
Donc, regardons les plus grands pays du monde,
ceux qui contribueront le plus à l’atteinte des ODD ou pas.
Les voici -
les pays du monde ayant une population de plus de 100 million,
de la Chine à l'Éthiopie.
Évidemment, les USA et le Japon en font partie,
mais nous en avons déjà parlé.
Donc, les voilà.
Les plus grands pays du monde ; ceux qui feront ou pas le succès des ODD.
Et le pays qui va se rapprocher le plus des ODD
est le Mexique.
Le Mexique va atteindre environ 87,
presque là où les Etats-Unis vont arriver
mais encore loin de la cible des ODD.
La Russie arrive ensuite.
Puis la Chine et l'Indonésie.
Ensuite le Brésil - on s'attendait à ce qu'il fasse un peu mieux.
Les Philippines,
puis un peu plus loin l'Inde, le Bangladesh, le Pakistan, le Nigeria,
et ensuite l'Éthiopie.
Aucun de ces pays n'atteindra les ODD.
Et nous pouvons récupérer les chiffres de tous les pays du monde
pour nous donner une prévision mondiale
de l'atteinte de l'ensemble des ODD.
Donc souvenez-vous, en 2015, nous étions à 69,1.
Je suis ravi de dire que les trois dernières années,
nous avons progressé.
En 2018, nous avons atteint 70,5
et si nous projetons ce taux de progrès sur 2030,
nous serons à 75,2
ce qui est évidemment loin de notre but.
En effet, au vu des tendances actuelles,
nous n'atteindrons les cibles de 2030 qu'en 2094.
Je ne sais pas vous,
mais je n'ai pas envie d'attendre aussi longtemps.
Que pouvons-nous faire ?
La première chose est d'interpeller les pays riches.
Voici les pays les plus proches des ODD,
ayant les meilleures ressources
et n'y arrivant pas.
Ils pensent peut-être que c'est comme le Vieux Monde
où les objectifs des Nations Unies
ne concernent que les pays pauvres et pas eux.
Eh bien, vous avez tort.
Les ODD sont pour tous les pays
et c'est honteux que ces pays riches n'y arrivent pas.
Chaque pays a besoin d'un plan pour mettre en place les ODD
et les livrer à leurs citoyens.
Le G7, autres pays riches -
réveillez-vous.
La deuxième chose à faire est de regarder les données de plus près
et voir où il est possible d’accélérer le mouvement
ou les tendances négatives que nous pouvons redresser.
Je vais vous emmener dans trois domaines.
Un où nous réussissons assez bien,
un où nous devrions vraiment faire mieux
et un autre où nous avons de vrais problèmes.
Commençons par les bonnes nouvelles,
je veux parler de ce que nous appelons
la nutrition et les soins médicaux de base.
Cela concerne l'ODD 2 sur la faim
et les éléments basiques de l'ODD 3 sur la santé,
donc la mortalité maternelle et infantile, les maladies infectieuses, etc.
C'est un domaine où la plupart du monde riche a atteint les ODD.
Et nous trouvons aussi, en regardant les grands pays,
que les plus avancés en sont très proches.
Voici nos 11 grands pays,
et si vous regardez en haut,
le Brésil et la Russie sont assez proches de la cible des ODD.
Mais en bas -
l'Éthiopie et le Pakistan ont encore du chemin.
C'est là où nous en sommes en 2018.
Quelle est notre trajectoire ?
Sur la trajectoire actuelle, où en serons-nous d'ici 2030 ?
Regardons.
Nous voyons une belle avancée.
Regardez le Bangladesh au milieu.
Si le Bangladesh maintient son niveau actuel d'avancement,
il pourrait se rapprocher de la cible de cet ODD.
Et l'Éthiopie en bas progresse énormément
en ce moment.
Si ça peut être maintenu, l'Éthiopie pourrait aller loin.
Nous ajoutons tout cela pour tous les pays du monde
et notre projection donne un résultat de 94,5 en 2030.
Et si des pays comme les Philippines, qui ont grandi moins vite,
pouvaient accélérer les progrès,
alors nous pourrions être encore plus proches.
Il y a de quoi être optimiste concernant les ODD 2 et 3.
Mais il y a un autre domaine de base des ODD où nous sommes moins bons,
c'est l'ODD 6 sur l'eau et l'assainissement.
Encore une fois, c'est un ODD où la plupart des pays riches
ont déjà atteint la cible.
Et de nouveau, pour nos grands pays - nos 11 grands pays émergents,
nous voyons que certains, comme la Russie et le Mexique,
sont proches de la cible,
mais le Nigeria et d'autres pays en sont très loin.
Où en sommes-nous sur cet objectif ?
Quels progrès allons-nous faire ces 12 prochaines années
en fonction de la direction actuelle ?
Eh bien, voici...
Et oui, il y a du progrès.
Les quatre premiers pays atteignent tous les cibles de l'ODD -
certains avancent assez vite.
Mais ce n'est pas assez pour vraiment avancer significativement.
Ce que nous voyons, c'est que pour le monde entier,
nous prévoyons un résultat autour de 85, 86 d'ici 2030 -
pas assez vite.
Ce n'est certes pas une bonne nouvelle,
mais je pense que ces chiffres montrent que l'on pourrait faire beaucoup mieux.
L'eau et l'assainissement sont un problème résolu.
Il s'agit d'étendre cette solution partout.
Donc, si nous pouvions accélérer les progrès dans certains pays
qui s'améliorent plus lentement -
le Nigeria, les Philippines, etc.
alors nous pourrions nous rapprocher du but.
En effet, je pense que l'ODD 6 est probablement la plus grande opportunité
de tous les ODD pour un changement progressif.
C'est un domaine où nous pourrions mieux faire.
Regardons enfin un domaine où nous avons des difficultés :
celui que nous appelons droits individuels et inclusion.
Cela couvre les concepts de plusieurs ODD.
ODD 1 sur la pauvreté, ODD 5 sur l'égalité entre les sexes,
ODD 10 sur l'inégalité,
ODD 11 sur les villes durables,
et ODD 16 sur la paix et la justice.
Dans tous ces ODD, il y a des thèmes autour des droits et de l'inclusion
et ceux-ci semblent moins immédiats ou pressants
que des choses comme la faim ou la maladie,
mais les droits et l'inclusion sont critiques
pour un programme qui n'exclut personne.
Donc où en sommes-nous sur ces problèmes ?
Commençons par les droits individuels.
Je vais d'abord vous montrer nos grands pays en 2015.
Les voici,
et j'ai remis les USA et le Japon,
donc ce sont les 13 plus grands pays au monde.
Nous voyons une grande diversité de résultats.
Les États-Unis et le Japon en haut atteignant les objectifs ;
la Chine, loin derrière.
Donc quelle a été notre direction
concernant le programme des droits les trois dernières années ?
Regardons.
Ce que nous voyons n'est pas terrible.
La majorité des pays fait du sur-place ou recule,
et les grands pays comme le Brésil, l'Inde, la Chine et le Bangladesh
ont vu de fortes baisses.
C'est inquiétant.
Regardons maintenant l’inclusion.
L'inclusion concerne des choses comme
la violence et la discrimination contre les minorités,
l'égalité entre les sexes, l'inclusion des LGBT, etc.
Il en découle que les résultats pour nos grands pays
sont généralement plus bas.
Tout pays, riche ou pauvre, se bat
avec la construction d'une société inclusive.
Mais quelle est notre direction ?
Construisons-nous des pays plus inclusifs ?
Regardons... les progrès en 2018.
De nouveau, nous voyons que le monde recule :
la plupart des pays sont statiques,
beaucoup de pays reculent -
le Bangladesh recule -
mais aussi deux des pays qui étaient en tête -
le Brésil et les États-Unis -
ont reculé de façon significative
ces trois dernières années.
Résumons pour le monde entier.
Ce que nous voyons des droits individuels pour le monde entier
est une baisse des résultats des droits individuels
à environ 60
et ensuite cette baisse de résultat de l'inclusion à environ 42.
Ces choses peuvent évidemment changer rapidement
avec les droits et les changements de lois et d’attitude.
Mais les tendances actuelles doivent le prendre en compte,
c'est peut-être l'aspect le plus inquiétant des ODD.
Je vous déprime...
(Rires)
J'espère que non parce que je pense que ce que nous voyons,
ce sont des progrès dans plein de pays
et il y a des opportunités pour accélérer les progrès.
Nous vivons dans un monde tout près
de faire en sorte que personne ne meure de faim, de malaria ou de diarrhée.
Si nous pouvons concentrer nos efforts, mobiliser des ressources,
galvaniser la volonté politique,
ce changement progressif est possible.
En se concentrant sur ces ODD vraiment basiques et solubles,
nous ne devons pas oublier la vue d'ensemble.
Les objectifs sont un ensemble complexe d’indicateurs, objectifs et cibles
mais ils incluent aussi les défis auxquels notre monde fait face.
Le fait que les ODD concentrent leur attention
sur le fait que nous sommes dans une crise des droits individuels et d'inclusion
est positif.
Si nous oublions ça,
si nous choisissons de doubler la mise sur les ODD que nous pouvons résoudre,
si nous choisissons les ODD à la carte et que nous prenons les plus faciles,
alors nous passerons à côté de l'intérêt des ODD,
nous raterons les objectifs
et nous ne tiendrons pas la promesse des ODD.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)